so when i started
this stuff's very very common
i'm cutting down here
and everyone always has these little
tweaks right because sooner or later the
dude is so strong
you can't do it so they add these little
tweaks they think is maybe i'm actually
cutting here
right
oh i'm pulling over here when i do it
you get it i'm falling right i'm
pulling and pushing it's all
overpowering do you understand it's it's
all yong yong clash it's not aikido okay
so
you can go back and see old business i
used to do it like that
and now what basically i'm doing now i'm
doing
[Music]
the front edward kazushi you get it so
but that's a prescription that to me
that's a what-if technique it's not a
keyhole
because what if he did not come back up
that way and he turned around the other
way
the other way
you see well now i gotta go to something
else
do you understand there's no there's
there should not be a prescription
past the first move that's not kihon do
you understand
okay so
i go here
and now i finally go to this position
you see
well i go here
and now he comes out right now he's out
of kazushi
see there's another reason i don't want
to do it
if i got someone's balance here hope
this is where i attack
oh
you don't take someone into kazushi then
bring them back out of kazushi to take
them into kazushi again
but this part here everyone knows this
part here
oh it's pretty good
so
but because it's external
that guy has to be going
with you
okay
if it's internal if i release and his
energy goes through me i don't have to
be going
in the same direction that he's going
for me not to contest so he's pushing
and boom
i got the same thing
because he's bouncing off the glass
you can do the same homework
but it's not working because i'm making
his arm go into this shape and tilting
him
it's because he he actually is coming in
[Music]
and he hits something
at that angle
that's the ground
so even though my arm is your boom this
is where he hits it
so you don't have to do
it
with the arm movement well if i don't
have to do the arm movement then cut the
dirty is the same thing so boom
same thing
so i don't have to go
here i just use his initial movement
yield
boom
don't find the heel till it opens that's
just in place
get out of the way
project
go around the hand
don't go into it and try to move his arm
over
go around his hand
now this grip is exactly like katatadori
now it's weak
so
[Music]
boom
has in place but not being used
boom go around the hand now i have the
elbow
i control the elbow
and his hand will come last
oh
[Music]
same thing don't use the eq on the
elbows
let him hit the ground
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
your job is not to push on what's
pushing on you
hey
[Music]
keep going
switch roles
push into the ground let his energy go
down with your ground path
come on
[Music]
you don't need that little flexion
keep going
there you go
get around that fist don't be tempted to
push into it
there you go
[Music]
right there you could have gone around a
bit more
there you go
so here it
so is to push do you see
but
your hips are going to rotate though my
arms are going to this is not going to
be here i'm not going to enter here
i'm going to go i'm going to turn
you have to get it off first
it's off and now
it's very similar to me
when you try to do nikkyo from here
and you try to crank and you're not
cranking anybody you're not cranking
anyone
you have to figure out
how to turn
his body
how would my body turn his body now he's
fallen into nuclear
i'm knocking here here
crank this over
i'm going to use my body
to get to the outside using and there's
nikki
we're just using it now not to set up
nico
but to set up is right now there's an
obstacle oh i gotta go around it
here
you can see oh yeah there is
nikki
[Music]
here
no no
go around it
there
so if you want
push into it so you feel it
and then go around
[Music]
don't push always pushing on you
neutralize it reconcile it release
okay the urge to push on what's pushing
on you is attachment
release
release by neutralize i'm not going to
push on it i'm not going to push on
what's pushing on me i know
i'm creating the push by doing that have
enough faith to make that your reality
once it's your reality you can undo the
push
by not playing your part in it
okay so you're you're not doing
self-defense you're not trying to spin
ronin who cares
he's not the world's metric the
universal metric he cares
okay so as as we're going
i'm not going to go
here
i'm going to continue to work
short
these skills so he's going to go around
this other
his resistance i send him to the ground
not here
you